DAVID: Thank you all
for coming today.
We're here with
Morra Aarons-Mele,
the author of "Hiding
in the Bathroom:
An Introvert's Roadmap
to Getting Out There
When You'd Rather Stay Home."
If I may give a little
bit of a synopsis,
it's largely about
being an introvert when
you face things that are
difficult for an introvert.
It's been easier for many of us
to stay in a corner on our own,
but Morra's work has
forced her to go out.
And so she writes
about how to deal
with this tension, as opposed
to give up and stay away
from it altogether.
Please, round of
applause for Morra.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
Thanks, David.
Nice to see you.
DAVID: How would
you describe being
an introvert and the challenge
you face as a result of it?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I call
myself an ambitious introvert.
I don't know if that phrase
resonates with any of you.
I also have a lot of anxieties.
I have social anxiety.
I have flying anxiety.
You know, sometimes for me,
sort of leaving the house
and going out in the world
can be challenging, especially
in these times.
And yet, I run a
business and I chose
to write this book, which has
taken me out of my comfort
zone in every way possible.
Because it's the
manual that I wished
I had had when I was
trying to build my career.
I didn't know that
I was an introvert.
I had anxiety.
I just knew that I cried
a lot in the bathroom
and quit lots of jobs.
I felt like walking
into the office
some days was an
assault on my senses.
And you know, as I got
promoted in my career,
I worked in political consulting
and digital marketing.
And so as the sort
of demands increased
to run teams, run meetings,
collaborate, negotiate, sell,
network, all the stuff
that you really have to do,
I literally just--
I felt like it was an assault.
I didn't know how to do it,
and I didn't have a manual.
And so instead, I hid
a lot in the bathroom.
I still hide in
the bathroom a lot.
I don't know if you do, too.
I haven't been to
the bathroom here.
So I wanted to really
provide a really practical--
if you see the book,
it's super practical.
There's worksheets,
there's tear sheets.
And we take on business
development, networking,
how to survive a professional
networking event.
That's a huge one.
Social media, right?
How do you get out there?
Everyone says you
should get out there.
You should have a
personal brand, certainly,
as you grow in your
career, if you take
on a more public facing role.
And this is tough
for some of us.
DAVID: Most of the crowd
that I see here is engineers.
But as engineers, every time we
look for a job that's an issue.
But also, people who are
not software engineers
don't appreciate how
much collaboration
is part of the work we do.
We may be able to get by
with relatively little
if we only go to the things
that we are called to,
but if we have an idea we want
to promote, as you're familiar,
you need to get
someone's attention.
You need to push an idea
that maybe somebody doesn't
want to put his attention on.
And so some of these
things are certainly
more relevant to us in ways
other than your personal
experience, directly.
One of the things you've
described yourself as
is an ambitious overachiever.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Yes.
No one here is an ambitious
overachiever, I'm sure.
DAVID: Well, it's easy to
be an overachiever in ways
that are solitary
with our field,
until you get into industry.
When you're in industry,
you aren't just
writing a program anymore and
then letting the world see it.
You have to interact
with everybody
else who your software
is affecting in any way.
And how do you reconcile
having that urge to achieve
and facing the fearsome
dog ahead of you
that you don't want
to interact with?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: That's right.
And I think for something
like, I would imagine
if you've written something--
I have felt this way
about my passion projects,
and this is where
introverts can really
shine if we are
creative people, which
I believe software engineering
is very creative as well.
We have the ability
to have faith
in our project and our work and
to carry it to a certain place.
So how do you
translate that, not
only in being able to stand
up in front of a group
and sell in that vision,
which is an essential skill,
but be able to negotiate
with other people
to make your thing come to life?
And this can be
hard for introverts.
Sometimes, because we've
gotten feedback in our career,
even in school, that
we aren't heard, right?
Because we maybe
talked over a lot.
I don't know how many
of you have felt that.
And then of course there
are gender and race and age
implications and all of that.
Depending on where
you're at in your career,
you might get talked
over more or less.
And so I think one
of the skills that I
had to learn the hard way, and
that I encourage companies now
to teach, is how to help
that ambitious introvert
with an idea.
Negotiate it.
Sell it.
You're not born
learning how to code.
learning how to know
Excel or PowerPoint or Keynote
or any of these things.
You're taught.
And so one of the things that I
think we have to seek and give
in companies is how
to birth your idea
socially in the office culture.
DAVID: At Google, many
of us, perhaps not
a predominant fraction,
but many of us
have not had a very social
experience before coming here.
And so many of us are shorter
on those social skills
and would benefit from them.
But it sounds like this
is general useful advice
for companies to help
their employees thrive.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: And you
have a rich peer culture here,
which I think can
be really valuable.
You know, I always say that it's
great to adopt an extrovert.
If there is someone who
you see has that skill
set, whether it's being able to
have someone see their vision,
being able to
negotiate and listen.
I mean, one of the things that
introverts are really good
at-- and if you can think
of selling in your software
project as a sort
of negotiation--
is it may be tempting
for us to sort of learn
to go in and tell everyone
about our project.
But one of, I think, the
natural skills of introverts
is that we do absorb
and we tune in.
And so before you sell--
and I have this in the book
in the chapter on selling
and negotiate--
read the room.
tune in to the other conditions.
Do your research.
We're very good at preparing.
And the layer of sometimes
those of us with anxiety
makes us prepare even more.
And so you can learn how to
use your introvert-like super
powers to actually take a step
back and sell in a project.
DAVID: You describe yourself
as somewhat of a hermit,
an introvert, socially anxious.
I know these aren't synonyms.
They aren't distinct.
Could you talk about
where they overlap
and what the different--
introvert is one
that I didn't even understand
until a few years ago
when I learned from a friend.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
There's a lot of myths
about what an introvert is.
There's a lot of great books
and literature out there,
and I think it's becoming much
more socialized and acceptable.
We understand that we are
born probably more introverted
more extroverted.
It's not something
that we learn,
although most
introverts, we learn
how to fake it at
some point, certainly
if we're going to go out and
sell or be public in any way.
I was on "Boston
Public Radio" last week
and Jim Braude said
to me, well, you
don't seem like you
suffer from introversion.
I mean, you can make
eye contact with me.
And you're laughing.
I was like, what are
you talking about?
Introversion doesn't necessarily
mean that you're quiet.
It doesn't mean even
that you're shy.
Actually, if you're
shy it may mean
that you have social anxiety,
or if you're just a little shy.
An introvert is someone
who needs time and space
and does great work alone,
who gets that creative energy
alone.
And when you go into
overwhelming situations,
whether it's walking
into a hotel lobby
with lots of fluorescent
lights and noise,
or an open plan
office, frankly--
I mean, I'm obsessed
with open plan offices
and I have a whole
chapter in the book
about how to survive an open
plan office or pod situation.
If you feel like I do,
like you're Superman
and the kryptonite is
draining your energy,
you're probably an introvert.
But it doesn't mean you're
quiet or that you don't talk.
It just means that
you recharge and you
need more quiet environment
to do your best work.
And you like to be
alone with yourself,
which I think is amazing.
Social anxiety is another layer
that I talk about in the book
and that I separate out.
Because many of us, whether
we're awkward as kids,
or no one will sit
with us at lunch,
or we have whatever
kind of trauma,
we have intense performance
anxiety and fear
of social situations,
even picking up
the phone to call a
colleague or a client.
Walking into a meeting, we
assume people won't like us.
And again this is
a real challenge
as you grow in your career
and you have to sell.
Being a hermit is a--
I use a tongue in cheek.
I actually trademarked the term.
I'm a hermit entrepreneur.
And this is my choice.
I left corporate America
about 10 years ago,
and decided that I was
going to work for myself.
I started a small business,
successful business,
small business.
I decided I didn't want to
become a corporate executive.
I didn't want to have a big
career in the typical sense.
I was willing to make less
money and have less power
systemically, because it
is that important to me
to work from home.
I mean, that sounds
ridiculous, but it really is.
I love to work from home.
I like to be by myself.
My favorite day--
and this may not
apply to you-- is a
day without meetings.
I mean, we were
talking about email.
Email is also a big sensory
overload for a lot of us.
But a day without meetings,
and time to think.
And so I created a
business that allows
me to build in days
alone, time to think,
and then I hit the road.
DAVID: How do you reconcile
being a mother of three
with having time alone at home?
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
It's hard, you know.
But I actually-- I
mean, oh god, this
feels horrible to admit--
but I build in my alone time
during my work day.
Because your kids
don't care, right?
Your kids don't care
if you need a break.
So what I try to do
is I try to protect
my time during the workweek,
actually, to get a lot of time
to think.
And I justify it
by actually saying
it helps me run my business.
It's where I have my best ideas.
It's where I come
up with solutions
and figure out how to pay for
things and hire new people.
But, yes.
DAVID: One of the complications
of working at home-- parent.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Yes.
Not everyone is made
to work from home.
It's a discipline.
I don't know if you have a
work from home policy here.
I think that some
people really seek it,
and some people it
drives them crazy.
DAVID: We were
talking earlier about
how social anxiety
and introversion can
be different for women than
men, broadly, of course.
It's not going to be
the same in every case.
Could you talk some
about how it differs
for women in ways that might
not be obvious to us or not?
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
I mean, I think
one of the things that has
been really remarkable to me--
and I love seeing so many men
here today-- is, you know,
I wrote the book sort
of geared towards women
because that's my bias.
I run a business
called women online
and I create political
and social marketing
campaigns that mobilize women.
But I think what's
interesting is
that men feel work-life
conflict, the tug between home,
work, the pressure.
Certainly-- I mean, this is
one thing I talk a lot about
in the book when you think
of sales and negotiating,
and again it's a bit different
maybe in an environment like
this, but you will come
up against it I think--
to be that sort of
alpha male salesman.
That's something that
women don't really face.
We face a lot of other biases.
But I've heard from
many introverted men
at work who feel
really frustrated.
One guy said to me--
I gave a talk last
week in Cambridge
and he said, how did the
extroverts when everything?
He felt in his work experience
that because he was more quiet,
he was not your typical sort get
out there kind of glad handler,
that he felt he didn't fit
in at his office, which
I felt was really sad for him.
So I think for men there
are barriers to feeling--
certainly if you do like
me, you're a hermit.
You love to work from home.
You like alone time.
You don't maybe want to go
out and take clients out
for drinks or dinner or
sell in all those ways.
That's a barrier.
For women, if we are
more introverted,
data show we are less
likely to get promoted.
We earn less money,
and of course women
earn less money anyway, and
we fight to get heard anyway.
So there's really a
double barreled assault
on women, I think,
who, again, may not
present in a typical
leadership fashion.
You know, you only have to look
at our politics to see right
now-- and I promised I wouldn't
get political but I can't help
it--
that too often, the salesperson
in chief wins in our culture.
Certainly, when it comes to
what we see as leadership.
I could not help feeling
all during the election
that Hillary Clinton
is really an introvert,
and if she could just sell
her policies in small groups
and connect in an
authentic way, things
would be so much different.
And yet we got the sort of man
in front of the room talking
and selling.
And I think that that's
powerful and that
extends to every
corporate environment
and every leadership
environment.
We need to think about
that, and gender is a piece.
DAVID: You wrote that you
would be more successful if you
went to cocktail parties more.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
37% more successful
if I went to cocktail parties.
DAVID: Could you explain that?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Absolutely.
I mean, I think
it's amazing, now,
that we have so many
online tools to network.
And I talk about that
a lot in the book.
In many, many
business environments,
we are obsessed with networking.
I call it an "enlightened bro."
There are guys like Gary
Vaynerchuk and Tim Ferriss
out there, and they're full
of tips to solve your life.
But if you watch any
leadership video on YouTube,
chances are there is going to
be something about getting out
there, about networking, still
the old chestnuts of never
eating lunch alone--
again, prevalent in our culture.
And if you're like me and
you're sort of allergic to this,
and you go to a professional
conference and think,
oh gosh, how am I going to
survive the cocktail hour?
I just want to go back to
my hotel room and hide,
or whatever meet up
group, or whatever
you're part of to sort
of advance your career,
and you know it's important.
Again, you can always
feel like you're at odds.
So I probably would
be more successful
if I liked networking
more, but I've also
made my peace with it.
And that's why for me,
blogging and participating
in online community has
been a savior, because I
can find connections online.
I can blog and connect with
people who care about what
I do, and it doesn't
matter if we're
going for drinks at the local
Hilton on a Tuesday night.
DAVID: You communicate
on your terms.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I communicate
on my terms from bed.
DAVID: Instead of party terms.
You hinted at having
advice for people,
for the most important
thing that they
could do when at parties.
Could you explain that?
I was curious what it was.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Yes.
Well, the last
chapter of the book--
and actually if you go on
hidinginthebathroom.com,
I have a 16 point guide
to getting out there
when you have to.
And one of the things
that I talk about is--
and again, this is
simple advice but it's
really, really powerful--
is that feeling of
anticipatory anxiety
when you have to walk
into a networking event,
or you have to go to a
presentation or meet a new team
or whatever you feel.
I think it's really important
to sort of physically
get a sense of yourself.
You know, actors do this
before they get on stage.
They check in with themselves.
They check in with
their motivation.
Why am I here?
I feel that all the time.
I want to be at home.
Why am I here?
I don't want to go on
this business trip.
I'm scared.
I don't want to
walk in this room.
Why am I here?
Sometimes it's as simple
as I have to pay the bills.
That's legit.
Sometimes it's I
care about my work.
I want to share
what I've written.
I want to bring this.
So checking into the meaning
and checking into your body.
For me, also-- and I don't
know, this is different
for everyone--
I have clothes that I wear.
Literally, I'll
put my lipstick on.
I will put on my armor
and become the person
who would play me in the movie.
Because I can then get
that person out there.
And then I follow what my
friend Dr. Ellen Hendrickson
calls the 10 second rule.
She's a social psychologist.
You can do anything
for 10 seconds.
You can even put your feet
over fire for 10 seconds.
So just give yourself that push.
Walk into the room or walk
up to someone and say, hi.
And then muscle
memory takes over.
The other tip that I have--
and this is one that I actually
talked to a lot of people
about.
You'll hear this a lot.
I call it channeling
your inner Oprah,
but some people play journalist.
You know, especially
if you're an introvert,
you don't like the spotlight.
Ask people questions.
Again, tune in to other people.
You don't have to be the
best conversationalist
to be remembered as a
great conversationalist.
Because if you're
present with someone
and you can ask them questions,
they'll think that you are.
Anyway, I have lots
of other good tips,
but one thing I
also wanted to say
is to give yourself a reward.
This is something
that you can think of,
if you're at a
professional conference--
did you know that
there, I think it's
137 professional
conferences in the US a day?
It is the most booming industry.
And so again, the way that
we're taught now, to network
more than ever,
we're also expected
to go to conferences more
than ever, which is weird.
I mean, certainly in tech,
conferences are out of control,
right?
So for me, I'll do my research
about who I want to meet.
I'll say I got to
meet three people.
And then I let myself leave.
Sometimes I'll go
hide in the bathroom
or I'll go hide
in my hotel room.
And it's OK.
DAVID: Set a quota.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Set a quota.
Set a goal.
DAVID: There's a
term that you used--
I didn't get to the
part of the book
where you explain this term,
but I'm curious what it means.
You mention achievement porn.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
Achievement porn, yeah.
DAVID: Could you explain that?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: A while
back, I wrote an article
in "The Harvard Business
Review" about the rise
of entrepreneurship porn.
I'm glad you think it's funny.
I have been a sort of player
on the edges of the Boston tech
and VC scene, and
those sort of women
in tech scene for many
years now, and then in LA.
And it's very sexy to
be an entrepreneur.
It's very sexy to
work at a startup.
It's probably still
sexy to work at Google.
You know, so you guys have that.
But as you know,
from your friends,
whenever you work at a startup
or if you found a startup,
it's very sexy.
People want to talk to you.
You're an entrepreneur, right?
And so the media, and
networking culture,
and leadership talks, and
this whole conference industry
has really glamorized
entrepreneurship, especially
tech entrepreneurship, right?
It's made it seem like that's
what we should aspire to,
and scaling, and never sleeping,
and tirelessly fighting
until we get funded or we grow.
And I call it porn, because
you know it when you see it.
You read all these profiles of
these young entrepreneurs who
would stop at nothing and
made a gazillion dollars.
Very few of us can do that,
even if we're smart enough.
For me, personally,
and the people
that I interview in my
book and my podcast,
they didn't want to do that.
Some of us wanted to have really
great lifestyle businesses.
We needed to step back from
the entrepreneurship porn,
and the achievement porn, too.
You know, it's this
sense that if you
don't give 110%
every single day,
you're letting the side down.
DAVID: So it's the false image.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
It's the false image.
It's the glossy image.
Even failure is
sort of glamorized,
because we read a lot of
stories about these sort of epic
failures, certainly in
Silicon Valley and New York.
But they never really
feel like failures to me.
I don't know about
you, but they sort of
feel like just a blip in the
road till the next big one.
And life isn't like that.
DAVID: You mentioned the
tech industry's passion
for an entrepreneur who drives
an idea and starts a company.
But I feel like we're changing
more broadly than that.
More and more people are
expected to make their job,
as you've done, even
without building a company,
just as a sole contributor who
is also the CEO of the company,
you might say.
And that requires a lot of
social networking of sorts
as well, a lot of
often cold calling
to start a business that doesn't
exist because no one else
has done it for you.
Given that many of us,
well maybe not in this room
this year, but many
of the people watching
this may find
themselves in that state
while looking for
their next job,
finding that they need
to make it themselves.
If they prepare themselves
to walk into that room,
then they're talking
to the people
and their nerve fails them.
Do you have any advice
for how to pull yourself
back together when you feel
you're not up to the task?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I
mean, I think, it's again,
it's about tapping into the
meaning and the motivation.
I like to use the metaphor
of being a crafts person.
You know, if you
had built a house
that this really lovely family
were going to move into,
and you had lovingly taken
care of every element,
you would be proud
to talk about it.
I'm a big fan of
freelancing and consulting,
although there are many
things that are bad about it,
and you probably
will make less money.
You will have maybe less
of a systemic impact.
You've got to think
about health care.
But for many of those people,
or you, in five years from now,
if you leave this place
and go walk into a room
to make it on your own, even
if it is as a consultant,
don't feel like you
need to start afresh.
Often your best clients will
be your old company, the people
that used to work for.
An introverts gift is
actually managing a network
in a way that is good for us.
And so I find that
we're actually
good at sustaining those
long relationships.
I have a rule called the 10
touches, which is in the book.
I learned it from my husband,
my favorite adopted extrovert.
But for me, I can handle 10
business development touches
a week.
It might be just dropping you
an email, which I know now
you won't see, but that's OK.
It could be calling someone.
It could be recommending
someone on LinkedIn,
making some sort
of outward gesture.
I can do all of this
from my home office.
But if I have the discipline
of reaching out to 10 people
a week, and you can
do this actually
while you're working for someone
else to help build that network
and help build that future
network of potential employers,
funders, colleagues,
staff, whatever--
you know, I'm a big believer
in breaking things down
into bit-sized chunks,
bearable chunks.
So I do the 10
touches every week.
I keep my network
going, and so then I'm
never so scared to
walk into a room,
because I know why I'm there.
I try to have a sense that
I am not alone in this work,
if that makes sense.
DAVID: Thank you very much.
Is this a good time
for questions from the
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Sure.
Sure thing.
If anyone has questions.
AUDIENCE: So I don't know
whether the leadership
of Google would consider
themselves introverts,
like Larry Page and Sundar.
But they don't strike me
as the like, you know,
usual sort of CEO, right?
When you see them
speaking publicly
they're not as, you know,
comfortable or polished.
I don't know that have
a particular question,
but any thoughts
about that and kind
of tech leadership
in general, I guess,
and kind of where people fall
on the introvert/extrovert sort
of scale?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I think
that's really interesting,
and I was thinking about that,
actually, as I was coming in.
Again, coming back to
the fact that these
are skills that you learn,
I think that if you are you
are gifted and you create
an amazing tech company--
and I think of Bill Gates and
I think of all the leaders
of these big tech companies--
they are not necessarily
the most comfortable
public speakers, but
they give public speeches
every day when they reach a
certain point in leadership.
And I do think they
are changing the model.
I think that's really cool.
But what's interesting to
me is at the same time,
we have these leaders who
are changing the model
and do seem like
they're more introverted
and probably would be much
more comfortable in a smaller
group or one on one, or
even behind the screen.
We have sort of this
flourishing, how-to culture
of conferences and gurus
telling us to get out there.
And so to me, it's actually
a little confusing.
You know, should I
be a great networker
or should I just
pursue my own passion?
I think the answer is
pursue your own passion
and you'll figure it out later.
If you're good enough
at what you do,
no one's going to care if you
don't give a great speech.
And you will notice
that when they're
talking about things
they really care about
and they're really comfortable
with, they come alive.
They don't feel awkward anymore.
DAVID: I saw that
with a professor
when I was in undergraduate.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Yes.
DAVID: Sophomore classes,
he was like a robot.
Junior year classes,
he was a fire.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I
bet someone taught him,
or he just liked
that class better.
DAVID: It was the material
difference, not a change.
AUDIENCE: Oh, hi, Morra.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about creating
sort of like, space and
alone time in the businesses
you create.
Do you have recommendations
for how to do that
within a corporate environment?
Given that we are
in an open layout
and there's always a
lot of noise around us,
people are always
walking around,
or you just hear
conversations from people who
are sitting right next to you.
Yeah, do you have, I
guess, recommendations
for how to sort of carve out
that time for yourself, even
in that environment?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Yeah,
that's Chapter 10 in the book.
And to be honest, you
know, I think that it's
a very individual thing.
I hear you.
I hear you on the open plan.
I think that more companies--
and I don't know about Google,
and I'd actually be
very curious to know--
are building in
more private space,
especially with the rise
of pod based set ups
and sort of agile
everything where there is so
much collaborating happening.
I think people also understand
that individual teams might
want a quiet space
to collaborate,
but that people need a break.
We're all over meetinged.
I also think the rise of Slack,
and I guess here you use Gchat,
but you know, the constant
communicating not just
face-to-face, but online
while we're sitting publicly,
is very draining.
I think if you can, and you
are able to do your best work,
talking to your
manager, and you know,
if working from
home is your thing,
if there's a quieter place,
I think many of us are
socialized-- and I
totally understand it--
to be afraid to ask for what we
need to get our best job done.
But I have some amazing
statistics in the book.
Your boss will accommodate
you, because she
doesn't want you to leave.
It's very expensive and it's
a major pain in the butt.
And so being prepared, having
a plan, and saying, you know,
I have to get this project done.
I need quiet.
I will do my best
work in the quiet.
I'm going to take
three hours on Friday.
You have my cell phone.
I'm going to be on
Gchat, and just trying
a little bit of a
pilot and easing in
might be really effective.
But I think not being afraid
to say, we all feel that way.
It is a very
draining environment,
and so don't be ashamed.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming, again,
and I guess first thing
I'll say is that Google
has some very nice bathrooms.
So feel free to take advantage.
My question is, I
guess I find myself
in a little bit of a flip of the
situation that you described,
in the sense that,
like, day to day
I'm interacting with a
lot of people around here.
And outside of
that, I find I have
zero energy for
social networking,
like for online networking.
I have zero energy to put stuff
even on Google+ internally,
much less, you know, Facebook
or LinkedIn or whatever.
And it feels like there
are these very big channels
of being connected,
interacting with people,
having influence, blah
blah blah, that I'm not
participating in
because I just don't
feel I have this sort
of introvert energy
to participate in those.
Do you have any
thoughts or suggestions?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I just
want to say I hear you.
I feel the same.
I feel sometimes that
participating online
is almost more of a
challenge and that you
do have to force yourself.
But I would ask yourself why.
I think a lot of us feel
this sense of FOMO right?
I know I should be doing this.
I should be gaining influence.
I should be building
my personal brand.
My question is, why?
DAVID: FOMO-- Fear
Of Missing Out.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
Fear Of Missing Out.
So that's my question to you.
What's your motivation for
building the influence?
And then, OK, I want to write.
Do you want to make a
creative contribution?
Do you want to grow your network
for potential future career
opportunities?
Do you just want to build
your online landscape,
your online footprint,
your online profile?
Maybe pick one simple way.
For me, it's always
been writing.
I'm comfortable writing.
I like to write.
So blogging was
so natural for me.
And I didn't push myself for
the other parts of social media
that made me feel naked.
I think that there
are ways to build
your online footprint that
are less social, but equally
legit--
photography, video,
recipes, writing.
So maybe start there.
But I think it's
also OK to say, why?
Who says I have to
do this right now?
And like, baby steps.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
thanks for coming.
So I have a question
sort of on behalf
of my partner, who
is currently trying
to get a leg into a career
doing, like, animation.
And she's spending time
building a portfolio.
She's going to start
applying to jobs soon.
And I think she has a
challenge now where she's
an outsider looking to
break into an industry
where she doesn't have
a lot of connections.
What would you say
that someone like that,
who's trying to get into a
place where they're networking
and meeting people and
finding opportunities when
they're starting from zero.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
That's tough, right?
This is where conferences
actually can be very helpful.
And because she does want to get
into a very specific industry,
I mean, I would encourage her
to even go a little bit deeper
than animation.
You know, is there
a certain area?
Does she want to
do entertainment?
Does she want to do scientific?
Does she want to do technical?
I don't know.
But what I would
do-- honestly, this
sounds so basic-- is I
would start on Twitter
and use some search
term, seeking.
And find out who's writing--
this is what I would
tell my clients,
too-- who's writing about it?
Are there animators tweeting?
Who are people on YouTube
who have big followings?
I would start following them.
And I would figure out what
are the publications they site
or contribute to--
message boards, websites--
and is there a conference they
go to.
Honestly.
And then she needs to
have a battle plan.
I would challenge her.
If there's a conference in LA,
for example, where she says,
you know, potential employers
are going to be there.
This person that I really
want to work for is speaking.
That's the place where
she's got to have her plan,
and she's got to figure out her
online strategy ahead of time.
She's got a good website.
She's got a good portfolio.
Is she following the
right people on Twitter?
Go to the conference,
have a strategy,
try to meet five people.
Maybe she can bring
an extrovert with her.
And do it.
Because when you are
going to break in,
you sometimes have
to get out there.
And sometimes the face
time of a conference
is actually really great.
It just is.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Thank you.
DAVID: Typical sorts
of things to bring up
in a talk like this that don't
apply so much to Google are,
how are the workplaces
lacking in ways that
makes these challenges greater?
And how can the
companies change?
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I would
say just in general--
and I don't know if this
is an issue in Google.
I've never worked here.
I've read a lot about it.
My personal passion is
helping really successful,
ambitious people claim the
space and the quiet they
need to get their job done.
For a lot of people
it's working from home.
It's getting out
in the open plan.
There was a great
reported story on a blog
that, you know, the Apple
$5 billion headquarters--
it's all pod.
It's all open plan.
So one of the senior
engineers actually
had a bit of a palace
coup and insisted
he have his own building
with private spaces built.
I don't know if that's true
or not, but I was like, yes.
So if I had one dream
for workplaces to change,
it would be that managers stop
looking at the person who's
always in the office as
their most ambitious person,
and look at the person
who does the best work.
I feel that, again, we equate
face time, seeming enthusiasm,
team spirit, all this stuff
with ambition and skill,
and that's actually
not the case at all.
If I could have grown
through the corporate ladder
and worked from home
two mornings a week,
I would have been really happy.
So I would like people to
stop, to decouple ambition
from face time, and
certainly from extroversion.
AUDIENCE: I was going to say--
I don't if this is a question
or a response to something
that somebody else asked, but
are you familiar with "Rest"
by Alex Pang.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Yes,
I quote it in the book.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because he talks
a bit about many intellectuals
or quiet people or
whatever who, you know,
would do an hour or
two of work, and then
go out on a walk for an
hour, hour and a half,
something like that.
And to me, I have
certainly done that here
at Google when I need
quiet time by myself
to think about something.
The problem is, you can't
bring like a laptop with you
and type.
But around here,
sometimes that's
the only time you can
get quiet for 30 minutes.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: I just
want to acknowledge that
and to say, again,
it sounds so basic,
but the ability to
claim your time to think
is really powerful.
And I know that Google's
always been a leader
and that you've had your--
is it 20% rule, or whatever?
But you know, so few
places in our life
give us a moment to be with
our thoughts and get creative.
And that's a discipline at
work that we need to honor.
AUDIENCE: I had
another question.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Since you brought
up Hilary's campaign,
I was curious--
yeah, I guess if
you were going to do
that, having those [INAUDIBLE]
conversations, how would you
have gone about, I guess,
like changing the way that she
sort of went across America
and had these conversations?
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
Oh, so politics.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious.
Yeah, it's not really like a--
MORRA AARONS-MELE: No, you know,
I have been thinking about this
because as a sort of digital
political consultant,
I've been thinking, and there's
actually a candidate running--
you should check
out, Laura Moser,
in Texas-- who started something
called the daily action,
which is online action.
She's a bit of an introvert.
So I'm going see
how she's running.
Again, I think that we don't
always get the best candidates,
because so much of
being a politician
is that glad
handling small talk.
I mean, if we think walking into
a tech networking event is bad,
imagine walking into a firehouse
dinner in a different state,
firehouse breakfast every--
I mean, oh my gosh, that's
hell for an introvert.
So I would love to see
candidates win who could either
use online conversations.
You know, wouldn't
it be amazing if you
could have Skype
conversations, if you could
use all these tools
to connect with people
in a meaningful way,
convene smaller groups.
Usually small groups are just--
only high donors get small
groups now, high dollar donors.
And yet, politicians
are expected
to be so extroverted
at the detriment
to the skill of policy.
I think this is something
we're all going to deal with.
We're dealing with diversity
at work, work styles.
We're dealing with failed
styles of leadership.
I think we need to rethink all
of our different temperaments
and how leaders can be different
kinds of people to your point,
and that that will happen in
the next five or 10 years.
DAVID: Well, here's to seeing
how the future accommodates
and how introverts adapt.
MORRA AARONS-MELE: Ah, yes.
DAVID: Thank you
very much for coming.
MORRA AARONS-MELE:
Thanks, David.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.